an nra convention attendee was brutally
fact checked on video completely
disproven in real time and still says
well i still believe the same thing
this is an incredible
epistemologically instructive event this
is from our friends over at the good
liars who are doing such good work the
good liars are davrum stifler
and jason selvig
this is a great example about how
confronting people with facts is useless
in the face of their worldview and their
pre-existing notions if the facts
support their conclusion they'll use the
facts if the facts contradict their
conclusion they'll ignore the facts or
say the facts don't matter or that it's
fake news or whatever check this out uh
you
this is just unbelievable more people
and more crime is committed and more
people are killed with hammers every
year than guns
look at the facts i will look that up i
don't think that's true actually it's
true in the united states though sir
that is true look it up it's on you can
google it
it's true it's actually true
so the number of murder victims and the
weapons used okay number one
handguns
8029 number two firearms type not stated
4863 number three knives are cutting
instruments personal weapons fists feet
uh then rifles
at 455. then blunt objects clubs hammers
uh
393. the the 300
the hammers that stat is just wrong back
to your question second amendment is
still my right and it's still important
to me
notice how confident this guy is in
something that is not only obviously
wrong
but verifiably wrong and verified to his
face
and notice how quickly he abandons it as
instructive and informative to his
opinion
going in part of his support for
firearms was
hammers are much more deadly
he's then shown hammers are not much
more deadly
the fact is completely debunked but now
his opinion is no longer based on that
now it's just it's in the second
amendment and that's it so the format of
this if we wanted to kind of um uh
boil this down to a kind of fundamental
logic the format is
here's something i made up
that supports my conclusion well but
that thing isn't true you just invented
that and it's wrong and then yes but it
actually doesn't matter and i still
believe the same thing because it didn't
really make a difference to my opinion
oh okay by the way think about hammers
for a second okay
imagine that we took away all the
hammers
all right
wouldn't deaths for deaths from hammers
go down they they almost certainly would
but people might replace the hammer with
something else like a gun well
if those looking to pil kill people with
hammers instead get a gun they'll
probably be able to kill more people do
any of us disagree with that no the gun
is much more deadly than the hammer well
then why isn't the opposite true right
if we take away the guns wouldn't deaths
from guns go down and they would say
yeah but they might get something else
like a hammer well you're going to kill
way fewer people with a hammer than with
a gun they it's sort of like the logic
is accepted by almost everyone when you
go hammered a gun
if you hand someone a hammer versus a
gun who are they most likely to be how
many people are they most likely to be
able to kill people accept it going one
direction but when you say well if
everybody was if the mass shooters all
had swords
wouldn't they kill fewer people no
they'd still figure out a way to kill
just as many people because the guns
aren't really a factor what
that doesn't make any sense makes no
sense at all so an incredibly
instructive moment
remember the facts only matter if they
are convenient and if they aren't
convenient they no longer matter we'll
have this clip on our instagram page
which you can find at david pakman show
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 percent off all products and free
shipping go to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below